- All right.
- Nice hose.
So one of the classic
things to do in slow motion
is to do a water balloon,
full of water popping,
looks cool, and we've done
plenty of that over the years.
- I thought that was a
pretty small balloon, though.
- It was.
That was actually a balloom
only this big, stretched out.
- It was about that big
when it was fully sort of.
- Get rid of that.
And, um.
Use this.
- Whoa, yes!
- So let's see how we get on, yeah?
Look how tiny that.
- Oh, god, it's stuck together.
Yeah, I'll do that.
- All right, let's move
all the cameras back.
Don't you dare claw this.
Aren't you going to be in for
a surprise when this pops?
I know how much you hate water.
- [Daniel] Does she hate water?
- Yeah.
All right, yeah?
That's full enough.
This is gonna suck, ready?
Ready?
- [Daniel] Yeah.
- [Daniel] Do you want me to shoot it?
It took all my weight.
This is got to make it
go, if I keep doing this.
This calls for slightly
more desperate measures.
- [Daniel] I'm slightly
concerned about this.
I do not think this is a good idea at all.
Get back in the tree.
Jump out.
- [Female spectator] Oh, my goodness.
- Hello, gov.
- What about you?
- I'm George.
- Yeah, but what are you to me?
- I'm your brother.
- Right, should we jump
on this bastard together?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- I'm just gonna do this,
just gonna back drop it.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
There it is.
- Made a bit of a flood.
Let's do it again.
- Huh ah, huh ah, huh ah.